black guy must always die first and and
women too shall die except for one never
bring an extra flat your car hey leave
the lights on when you turn it off you
boys go check it out below we're really
high yeah tell everybody you'll go into
the high reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
jonald I'm Perry Perry Nemiroff is with
us today horror fanatic and she has her
own YouTube channel guys go check it out
right away so we're gonna do a video
today I don't know exactly what the
title of this video is it's whatever the
title of the video is as we're filming
this we don't have one you see over at
her patreon where we do a lot of [ __ ]
David Gandy he is one of our top pledges
over there and one of our reward tiers
is whatever video you requested was
definitely covered and put up on the
youtubes and he asked for something that
is not a reaction and I'm always making
jokes about how people don't ask for
stuff that's not reaction related
thinking that like I think we're more
than just reactions and now we're put in
a position where we haven't really had
time to prepare for a discussion video
so let's see how this turns out
basically what we all think is required
to make a great horror film and we just
have bullet points that we quickly rode
up but you know I feel like we've all
seen especially you two haven't seen so
many horror films I've seen a pretty
good amount of horror you know I watched
hocus pocus when I was a kid
Christmas night before Christmas was a
terrifying film when I was younger great
pumpkin generally mag har that was the
hardest pg-13 film I've ever seen
awesome scary man I've experienced it
all so I say we just hop right into this
I mean maybe we could have done this
with a list but let's just see what we
spit ball here John what's like one of
the main things you think it takes to
make a good or great horror film I am
going to start off in boring
and and I'm gonna say let us get to know
your characters no matter what horror
film you're trying to tell we need to at
least have some info on these people so
that we can care about them it doesn't
matter if it's a slasher it's demon
movie it's found-footage whatever it's
not gonna be tense and tension is key
unless we care about who we're following
or at least have some kind of resonance
with them interesting you said you had
like a boiling point yeah I called it my
like bullet point supreme because this
is what it always comes down to you kind
of just like tapped into it a little bit
I feel like so many people go into our
horror movie they just want like the
cool kills there's something flashy to
happen and really none of that matters
if you don't have a good script and a
good story and strong characters that's
really what it all comes down to because
if you have the nuts and bolts of that
hmm anything can be terrifying
when it's earned through things like
that and even things that aren't as
overtly terrifying can be more
terrifying you have that day I have the
haunting of Hill House on my mind right
now because I'm obsessed with it but
that's the perfect example to me of a
very recent TV show that is a million
times more scary because you're so
invested in that family and because of
the way the story in that is structured
that is all I have heard about their
show so far is like the character stuff
all I want to do is watch that show over
I got a disagree with you guys I think
that if you put jump scares in more
often I think that matters more than
character worth honestly here's what I
want from character work right some
teenagers I think if we just get some
good like maybe hot white teenagers
maybe a black guy you throw them in
there and that's all you really need to
make it good like I'm thinking Jason
Takes Manhattan I'm thinking Halloween 5
whatever something about Michael Myers
revenge yeah something like that where
you don't really need what you need a
lot of gore and a lot of kill I'm
thinking like saw five you know I think
this small piece of me is dying and
but you know what saw 5 didn't even have
those boobs got a half so you gotta have
boobs boobs see this is why I went on
movie fights mm-hmm I can persuade
easily this is why we need to play movie
I mean John brings up a good point like
every movie has characters but how many
movies have boobs not the kids on the
couch scream when they're watching
Halloween our goal in life is to be
known those people that's a viable dream
more than ever okay my real contribution
that I don't think a lot of people are
aware of it goes in tune with character
though I think of like the conjuring and
I haven't seen the haunting of house but
I imagine it does this to is to not have
every scene be a horror scene like that
it seems like a weird thing to say it's
like if you watch a comedy you need
majority of that to be funny plain and
simple you know what makes most horror
movies really work is when you have
great scenes that are not horror scenes
I feel you can do a good horror movie a
great one where you have character work
wrapped up in the horror for sure but
something about like the conjuring that
I love is when they're just kickin it
with the family I'll sometimes for again
like oh yeah [ __ ] we're watching a
horror movie there's gonna be horror
scenes coming around and that's not that
scary of a movie all male that's not
that's but it's a damn good film and I
feel like character work is the main
ingredient for any genre and when you
get that in a movie you get more than
just a good horror movie you get a good
film yeah and I feel like that actually
takes the horror element and makes it an
invasive presence for the movie yourself
you know which is key I thought you were
gonna say atmosphere too because
boathouse and conjuring heaven say that
yes Bjorn it makes me think about a lot
of Stephen King's work and why that
storytelling that basically becomes I
mean it almost becomes a part of you it
consumes you it becomes a part of your
life because he's a writer who goes that
extra length to actually set the scene
and let you live with the characters
live in a specific
before anything scary actually happens
and you walk away feeling like you've
had such a well-developed like thorough
scare
yes I completely agree with that like
the same things you would say for any
great film you would say it for a horror
movie and I kind of find it funny that
when people try to dissect what makes a
good horror movie I'm like it's the same
[ __ ] there's a part for it it really is
like tone mood I feel like finding that
with a horror movies especially
important because I'm you think about
the shining that constant deliberate
pacing that dread feeling throughout or
something like the thing 'man which is a
completely different kind of horror
movie but the sense of isolation that's
developed throughout that whole film
like knowing your tone but then also
having touches that are not horror in
the thing it's not always a crazy
creature feature some of the intensity
of that film comes from when they're
turning on each other in a psychological
format of like Estes who had you know
Kerberos trying to figure it out they're
all gonna kill Kurt Russell or even in
the shining when they're on the road
trip it's still kind of creepy ominous
tone but him laughing with them those
elements always add such an extra
dimension to it I feel like for anything
to be effective in any movie you have to
let the audience feel what the opposite
is as well can I give a backwards bullet
point like a bullet point not to do that
I think a lot of our movies fall into
this don't just kill a character for the
sake of killing a character yeah it
can't just be a kill to kill that kill
needs to have value whether it's because
you've grown attached to that character
or you're doing something innovative
that nobody's seen before or that kill
is gonna further the story overall
because my genre love comes from scream
I am just like the queen of 90s campy
slasher flicks and a lot of it is just a
body count like going after one teen
after the next but you can't resort to
that no all the time I think there's
certain movies that play into that vibe
and do it well but they find a way to
justify it but there's a lot of things
out there that I keep seeing where it's
like oh we're 15 minutes in I know
someone's got a knife yeah I think even
with something like scream that's a
great example of character work without
going like what's this whole person's
history you know like jus Barrymore that
death is so impactful but you don't
really know who she is but you know
enough to know that she's a character
that
gieux Barrymore has done enough homework
on to have developed she has a boyfriend
and all that stuff and yeah stunt
casting too because it's the fact that
it's drew Barrymore at that time you
know she had prominence at the moment so
yeah we can automatically fill in the
blank with her and you know to make that
moment casting it's also the innovation
of the entire scene the idea of someone
calling and being like what's your
favorite scary movie yeah yeah really
the whole way the sequence progresses
after that I'll never forget sitting in
the theater seeing that for the first
time with my mom and she just couldn't
believe what was playing out on the
screen because we had never really seen
a kill sequence quite like that I think
with good character work - what do you
have to make sure you encompassing this
goes for any film is what is the overall
theme of the movie and what is this
character's goal because a lot of times
movies just set out to try to like kills
or scares but if there's nothing
underneath that to give it that extra
layer of nuance then you kind of got a
bland horror film it's like it's all the
same [ __ ] you would say for any movie
but like I think we're a horde
especially to be effective that has to
work I'm going back to the movie the
thing because I watched it very recently
again I'm like I don't really know these
guys I don't and I don't even know why
they're actually there like I've seen it
twice now I'm like why are they here
there's no I can't even recall one but
you could tell through the dialog that
they're fully realized characters and
that's enough to make you care about its
dynamics more than just what's their
background is that enough to care about
them the dynamics of how they interact
with other characters is a major effect
into what goes on for the rest of the
movie as well yeah that stuff can sail
why I feel like a lot of people mistake
character development for just oh let's
show some family photos or a flashback
or something yeah really it's it can be
as simple as why some a Tarantino movies
work is because it's like Oh what would
these two be talking about that can
showcase their personality in a fun way
and so yeah things like that are super
important and going back to the point
you made about scenes with different
tones in a horror movie I feel like so
much of what I wrote down for this is
all riding off the idea of tension and
release and contrast because the key to
any and all suspense and tension is that
contrast and and the key to any script
is really taking the idea of here's the
regular world here's what's about to
flip about it and in a horror movie the
flip is just really sinister and so I
feel like especially when
talking about atmosphere things like
silence versus shrill sound are very
important because I feel like it's easy
to forget about those like a quiet place
came out this year and also during
Halloween there were a couple sequences
where I was like this audience is so
quiet right now yeah that can be super
gripping that can be even more
terrifying than having stuff with music
or on the flip trill sound is so jarring
and so claustrophobic it's like you can
use elements like that to really in
clever ways make your horror that much
more potent so it's not just about kills
even or even the story it's in the sort
of oral visual presentation and design
is so important for her because I'll
just never forget the process of making
my own horror movies and shorts and film
school and you sit there and you watch
the footage with nothing under it but
then the second you I mean even putting
in something silly like footsteps that
could completely change how you view a
scene another really small like
seemingly trivial detail that's really
important for building tension and
building dread is insert shots make a
movie you go oh I want to get the big
wide shot the hero shot the one that
everybody's gonna remember but there's
all these little details that you need
in order to pave the way for the big
kill and it's so easy to overlook the
importance of those tiny details
I think build-up is very important I
also think minimizing your CGI is
important too like I can't really think
of a horror movie that had sequences
where it's only see cuz anytime it's
only CGI it pulls you out especially in
horror because the whole point is
nightmares come to life and the more
you're sitting there going to idea of
when you see something terrible happened
to a character that you love you can
almost feel the pain yourself to to a
degree and the second it becomes
something that's very you know digital
and done in post it loses that that
touch I think for a horror psychological
thriller putting you in their shoes if
you know it's almost everything we're
saying it always comes back to the
character and there's a reason why is
because if you not have put the audience
and like the movie hereditary is like a
horror drama
did you like the movie I can't remember
I liked it a lot except the ending
didn't work for me that tends to be the
common consensus with that film oh yeah
like hereditary they cuts back and forth
Disney Toni Collette in and I can't run
with the sons named Alex dwarf II was
that Collider was yeah yes he's amazing
in that film and he stole the shown
Jumanji welcome to the jungle
[Laughter]
yeah whenever you're with Alex Wolford
with Toni Collette you were in their
shoes and I think that's also another
very important thing to do is put you
into character shoes and another thing
not to do I think out of any genre where
I often feel smarter than the main
character or any of the characters its
horror so if you can make a horror movie
good make sure they're making decisions
where you're not like that's stupid I'm
smarter than this character yeah unless
you're writing a parody or something I
kind of have grown tired of this sort of
it's a horror movie logic yeah that's
the thing with people who see horror
movies all the time is you also start to
learn I mean it's not even just logic
it's you've seen it done before and you
know it's gonna happen a certain way
because of how a different movie it are
yes yeah it's too often man that's why
ice cream is also genius because it
plays on all those genre tropes in a
really cool way yeah yeah I know screams
my favorite horror movie of all time is
that yours that is it's my favorite
horror movie of all time and my second
favorite movie of all time
what's your first Jurassic Park what's
your third that's also a whole three
four and five move around a little bit
for me should I say Park three four five
no I do really like lost world Oh mine
are passion of the christ' Apocalypto
Lethal Weapon 3 something common with
those zones but I can't quite pinpoint I
think they're all comedies one thing
that I wrote down that is a bit of a
specific thing for me and I don't
necessarily think that perhaps every
horror movie has to have this element
but I really appreciate when horror
especially bothers to embrace weirdness
and things that are especially surreal
because there aren't a lot of genres
that I feel like directly call for just
overt strangeness because things that
are hard to understand are just
unsettling by design and you can get
weird in a horror movie the way you
can't in any other genre or at least the
way that you would have to work really
hard to justify on a whole other level
in any other genre and I feel like some
of the stuff I love the most these days
and some of the stuff that sticks with
me the most is rather strange and weird
and that helps you be original but again
that also helps you slip under people's
skin and stay there you know and so yeah
I always appreciate weirdness yeah I
mean to sum it up it all comes down to
character elements that make a movie
focus really hard on all of them and
also not taking the easy route yeah
because I feel like that's why we need
to have these discussions about haar
specifically more so than with any other
genre is because the idea of the cash
grab I think is more prevalent in horror
than any other genre because it's the
genre where you could have the highest
guarantee of making the quickest buck
doing something that had already been
done before and we tend to see a lot of
it and then all of a sudden we get a
movie like her editor and it's like oh
like if you actually put a little
thought into the character and why the
horror of the situation is infused in
their lines and tearing it apart then
you have this lasting effect yeah it
comes down to more than just making
characters likable it's more like this I
love Laurie Strode in the recent
Halloween movie so I really care about
her so that time it gets to the finale
it's intense and I fear for her and I'm
like is this movie gonna piss me off and
kill her I have that feeling but then
you can make a movie like Henry portrait
of a serial killer or you can make the
Devil's Rejects where you have
characters who are not good guys there
are terrible people or American Psycho
which is a horror movie in and of itself
and on the scary film but it still has
the horror static you can make those
kind of movies but as long as you can
make good character that are fascinating
and interesting to watch you got a
[ __ ] movie your hair it's really that
separates you can relate to someone or
just being able to understand that's why
we can have movies from the perspective
of let's say a killer
if you can convince somebody of why they
do what they do then a lot of the work
is done yeah yeah and take everything we
said and ply tune every John Ruth this
video pleasure all genres in every job
you should have a moment where these you
should have mode where they hear
something in the background and then
they jump and it's just a cat oh yeah
yeah all characters in horror movie guy
have a cat no I'm pretty sure it's the
opposite there should be no pets in any
horror movie ever ever yeah by the way
this is a sponsored video from Pet
Sematary I don't watch that movie coming
out soon alright guys well what do you
think it takes to make a horror movie
work I really can't think of anything
else I mean there's only so much that
you could say across the board then
we're gonna get into like personal
preference I prefer metaphorical mom if
there's one other thing I can add to
horror and I feel like Marvel does this
really well is knowing what associative
category the horror movie has with it
like horror it can be kind of just a
broad thing to say knowing if your film
is a monster horror film a supernatural
horror I'm a psychological horror film
knowing what that additional genre is to
your [ __ ] to me hereditary is a or
drama yeah like it feels like a movie
that's about mental health and it's a
horror film yeah so knowing what your
sub-genre is also makes a big difference
working with in your jaw Nora alright
guys well what do you think it takes to
make good horror boobs you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation also you
know male nudity goes a long way to I
want to make the first slasher movie
that has a higher percentage of dicks in
it I just I want that to be my stamp
check us out on patreon who or we got so
many goodies over there Terry Nemiroff
has a channel that is so good
you will unsubscribe from most YouTube
channels so you only get notified to put
all your attention on her but don't
unsubscribe to this one
oh really yeah so it's okay you choose
automatic you're doing summer air yeah
yes stop that sayonara peace